WITH LAMELO BALL.
KELLY OUBRE STARTS FOR THE
THIRD TIME ON THEY ARE.
GORDON HAYWARD, MIBOSTON.
TATUM.E
FIRST 12 MINUTES, THE FIRST 24.
YOU DONE THAT TOO.
>> HORNETS IN DOUBLE FIGURES IN
EVERY , FOUR REBOUNDS.ll:  EYES
DINNERHAS TAKEN
OVER THE LEAK.
>> Eric: THAT WAS CLEAN.
PRITCHARD STEALS IT AWAY.
JABASECONDS
OF THE FIRST  THREE BALL.
>> Dell: HARD STEP.
GIVES HIM SPACE TO KNOCK THAT
DOWN.
>> LEANS BACK.
YOU THTHE
CLUB  THIS YEAR.
BRIDGES. !ARS, THE HORNETS ARE
NOT ONCE.
THE FIRST TIME IN CHINESE
HORNETS LEAD AXIS TO PLAY DISCO
EARLY ENTRY TO GAMES AND MORE.
CALL 704 HORNETS OR VISIT
HORNETS.COM. ARTER FOR
JAYSON TATUM.
15 POINTS GOOD HANDS.DECISIONS
THE BALL.
>> Eric: SECOND DUNK OF THE LaM
HE DOESN'T SHOOT LIKE THAT.
>> IN THE PASSING LANE.
NO ONE IN FRONT OF HIM..  TATUM
BREAK.TIME .  KNICK
THE HORNETS HAVE IT.
A CORNER THREE.
>> OT CLOCK DOWN TO 4.
JABARI PARKER . RICHARDS TO
MILES
TATUM.
>> Dell: HE HAS A CHANCE TO BE
MATCHUP WI
CORNER.
TWO HANDS.0.
VIRGIN TERRITORY.  ON THIS END
THE FLOOR NOW.
TAKING IT  OUT OF BOUNDS.
>> Eric: GORDON HAYWARD WILL
TRIGGER  THE INBOUND.
ALL!  TODD CHANCE.
SCHRODER !TATUM.
THIS IS BROWN.
-2022 CAMPAIGN.
THIS ONE IS A FINA